[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance we may have just heard the
most carefully crafted sentence
structure in American political history
and that sentence structure has
condemned Donald John Trump according to
its director the FBI is quote
investigating the nature of any links
between individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government not possible links not if
there were links links any links period
the FBI's investigation is about the
nature of the links director Comey used
a caveat a minute at that hearing he
made no such disclaimers about links
between individuals associated with the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government to him under oath in front of
Congress they exist thus the
intelligence community is investigating
links between the victorious
presidential campaign and the Russians
thus the intelligence community has been
investigating links between the
victorious presidential campaign and the
Russians since last July thus the
intelligence community will be
investigating links between the
victorious presidential campaign and the
Russians indefinitely no time print no
end date what's the usual length of such
an investigation there is no usually
says combing I firmly believe that
almost any other American politician
hearing these words from the director of
the FBI to the house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence would have
resigned the presidency before noon I
have been authorized by the Department
of Justice to confirm that the FBI as
part of our counterintelligence mission
is investigating the Russian
government's efforts to interfere in the
2016 presidential election I also firmly
believe that almost any other American
politician hearing commis next words
would have not just resigned the
presidency before noon but fled the
country before nightfall and that
includes investigating the nature of any
links between individuals associated
with the Trump campaign and the Russian
government and whether there was any
coordination between the campaign
and Russia's efforts again note
carefully that grammar to paraphrase the
old insult the links we know what they
are we're now just arguing about the
price when representative Himes of
Connecticut came back to the point of
coordination and collusion and asked if
we should or should not dismiss it
call me confirmed that his sentence
structure any links was no accident call
me answered quote all I can tell you is
what we're investigating which includes
whether there was any coordination
between people associated with the Trump
campaign and the Russians for Comey
keeping his cards not just close to his
vest but sealed inside the deck these
comments were extraordinary and that was
just the start of Donald Trump's first
day of reckoning Comey dismissed
Trump's wiretap cloaks quote I have no
information that supports those tweets
Comey said his bosses dismissed Trump's
wiretap hoax quote the department has no
information that supports those tweets
Admiral Mike Rogers the head of the NSA
dismissed the news gossip cited by the
press secretary Spicer that the British
surveyed Trump pressed by mr. King of
New York to agree with the former
Director of National Intelligence
clapper that he had not seen proof of
any collusion between the Trump campaign
and Russia
King got nothing more from Rogers and
Comey than no comment and director Comey
and Admiral Rogers repeatedly swatted
away attempts by majority members like
Chairman newness and representative
Gowdy to elevate any procedural leaks or
their publication to the level of an
investigation of a foreign governments
efforts to alter the outcome of our
elections and the information they are
investigating that a foreign government
may have coordinated those efforts with
the winning presidential campaign and in
terms of the optics all this took place
the same morning as a series of panicked
hysterical chaotic tweets by Trump
insisting the Democrats made up and
pushed the Russian story as an excuse
for running a terrible campaign this
story is fake news and everyone knows it
quote the FBI as part of our
counterintelligence mission is invest
the Russian government's efforts to
interfere in the 2016 presidential
election and that includes investigating
the nature of any links between
individuals associated with the Trump
campaign and the Russian government and
whether there was any coordination
between the campaign and Russia's
efforts the story is not fake news the
story was not made up by the Democrats
it is not a story it is an investigation
by the FBI and its targets are Donald
Trump's men in short Trump got nothing
from Comey or Rogers or even any of the
Republican congressman backfilling on
his behalf who went so far as to imply
that the Russians have always supported
Republican presidential candidates
what's the big deal
sure like they supported Ronald Reagan
nothing there was nothing to keep Trump
from sinking the best news he got was
that there is an investigation but that
it has not yet reached its conclusions
the best news that he got is that the
drip drip drip of Trump and Russia and
Russia and Trump and what did Trump know
and when did he know it will continue
indefinitely that was his best news that
hearing could only have gone worse for
Trump if Vladimir Putin Michael Flynn
Roger stone and Vladimir Ilich Lenin had
been sworn in and confessed in the past
Trump has claimed that his favorite
motion picture of all time is the Orson
Welles classic Citizen Kane might be
true might not be true for all we know
he may never have seen it but one piece
of dialogue from that film kept playing
in my head as I watched this hearing the
corrupt politician whom Cain has
promised to lock up has discovered
Kane's own corruption that will cost him
the election he offers Kane a way out
that he realizes he's so sick that
you've got to go away for a year or two
but Kane cannot see the reality in front
of his face doesn't know it's over
doesn't save himself and his supporters
from humiliation and disaster and the
corrupt politician then says to Kane it
was anybody else I'd say what's gonna
happen to you would be a lesson to you
only you're gonna need more than one
lesson and you're gonna get more than
one lesson we're Trump smart he would
flee the country
now resist peace